surprise dave franco and alison brie are  married Alison's reps confirmed the  exciting news to ET though the  notoriously private couple kept detailed  very hush-hush for now we're pretty  relaxed about the whole thing he sat  down with the now you see me start last  June where he did admit they would  likely ditch some wedding day traditions  well I feel like when we do eventually  get married we're not going to do a lot  of the traditions and what's going to  make it easy and who knows  Alison shared a similar sentiment about  the whole thing  when we caught up with her at the  beginning of 2016 how our wedding plans  going that would give me so much anxiety  is there anything that's been  particularly tough so far no I'm just  avoiding it completely we've not planned  anything yet at all so that's oh I feel  totally calm do i right Oh  [Music]